[Música]
Bienvenidos a en 5 minutos el secretario
general de la ONU Antonio Gutiérrez
describió como un infierno climático lo
que le espera al planeta si no se actúa
Con urgencia para frenar el
calentamiento global hablamos con varios
expertos sobre el clima para entender
Cuáles son las acciones más urgentes
para la humanidad reducciones de las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
es la acción número uno a la que llama
la comunidad científica la acumulación
de gases de efecto invernadero en la
atmósfera como el CO2 o el metano
contribuye al calentamiento del planeta
que a su vez genera cambios en el clima
como sequías inundaciones extremas Omega
incendios ante todo lo primordial es
dejar de contaminar dejar de crear el
cambio climático y el cambio climático
se crea por las emisiones que generamos
de los gases de efectos invernales no
para minimizar la emisión de gases en
los expertos llaman a atacar
urgentemente sus causas el 90% de las
emisiones de efecto invernadero que
causan el calentamiento global se
resumen en estos cinco ejes de mayor a
menor
alimentación y uso de la tierra que
incluimos la deforestación electricidad
industria transporte Y por último
calefacción y refrigeración de edificios
según Naciones Unidas la producción
agrícola y otros usos de la tierra junto
a la deforestación causan el 24% de las
emisiones de gases contaminantes del
planeta solo la deforestación en la que
se liberan masivas reservas de gases que
suben a la atmósfera conlleva el 9% de
estas emisiones estos miles de hectáreas
que arden cada año dejan también de
absorber CO2 del entorno en tanto la
producción de Electricidad es
responsable de cerca del 25% de las
emisiones por ello los llamados a
acelerar la transición a energías
limpias ya están preparadas para asumir
toda la
demanda energética de la humanidad ya
hay más de 300 estudios científicos el
más alto nivel que confirman que es
posible
proveernos de Electricidad para todos
los usos energéticos de nuestra sociedad
de forma estable por su parte los
edificios son causantes en un 6% de las
emisiones su adaptación sostenible al
entorno es otra meta urgente necesitamos
transformar nuestras viviendas aislarlas
del exterior con buenas ventanas con
aislamiento térmico para reducir el
consumo las necesidades energéticas en
hasta un 90%. la industria por su parte
es responsable del 21% de las emisiones
entre tanto el transporte produce el 27%
de las emisiones por lo que se hacen
cada vez más importantes en los
vehículos eléctricos que dejen atrás el
consumo de combustibles fósiles por todo
ello los llamados a cambiar el modelo
actual basado en la extracción lineal de
recursos y a implementar uno que busque
menor impacto ambiental se han
convertido en un llamado de Socorro algo
clave y fundamental es abordar el mismo
sistema económico y financiero sobre el
cual está apoyado en nuestra
civilización como la conocemos tenemos
que poner en marcha una batería de
soluciones para reemplazar las viejas
prácticas intensivas en combustibles
fósiles y destructoras de la naturaleza
por técnicas más avanzadas que ya están
disponibles
otro gran esfuerzo para combatir el
cambio climático y sus efectos es el
seguimiento al clima de sus cambios si
yo quiero realmente determinar Cómo el
clima está cambiando yo necesito tener
mediciones de los parámetros temperatura
precipitación humedad
condiciones del suelo también que
realmente nos permitan monitorear como
es ese cambio y el tiempo y qué tan
rápido está sucediendo y para ello
aumenta la necesidad de financiamiento y
apoyo gubernamental te ven llenos asumir
compromisos más fuertes y las políticas
nacionales tienen que ser explícitas en
la inclusión de cómo está las diferentes
políticas y leyes que se vayan a
desarrollar tomen en cuenta el
fortalecimiento de los sistemas de
monitoreo adaptación y ayuda a los
países más afectados los efectos de la
crisis climática que son tangibles en
distintas partes del planeta y que no se
van a poder revertir es lo que se conoce
como pérdidas y daños y son
principalmente los países en desarrollo
los que están sintiendo estos estragos
como el aumento del nivel del mar
sequías extremas o mega inundaciones es
básico el financiamiento y es básico que
desde los países desarrollados se ayude
a los países en desarrollo los que menos
recursos tienen porque precisamente
ellos van a ser esas van a ser las zonas
más vulnerables del cambio climático no
solo por razones geográficas sino por
razones socioeconómicas cuantas menos
posibilidades es posibilidades tengas de
adaptarse Mientras menos sea robusta
reconocida para poder adaptarte más te
va a golpear el cambio climático Y es
que son los países ricos los que
históricamente han contribuido en mayor
medida al calentamiento con sus
emisiones de gases y a quienes se les
reclama una compensación finalmente en
medio de la lucha por el clima la acción
de los gobiernos se vuelve cada vez más
importante hace falta presión de la
sociedad presión de los de las personas
que
a las que eligen esos gobernantes para
que sepan que esto debe ser una
prioridad y hace falta que sus
gobernantes escuchen a la ciencia
actualmente el aumento de las
temperaturas está en los 1,1 grados
centígrados por encima de la era
preindustrial y los efectos del
calentamiento se sienten pero las
proyecciones muestran que nos dirigimos
a un calentamiento de 2,8 grados
centígrados para 2100 lejos del objetivo
del 1,5 grados que planteó el acuerdo de
París como un límite antes de un punto
de en la lucha climática de no actuar
las consecuencias se auguran
catastróficas por ello el llamado a la
acción es más urgente que nunca
definitivamente cuando vemos el
incremento de las emisiones que tenemos
año tras año no y a pesar de tener un
acuerdo como el de París de cambio
climático pues podemos decir que
llegamos tarde pero yo creo que aquí
cada décima de grado de calentamiento
importa y es mejor hacerlo ahora que no
hacerlo nunca se le sirvió el video para
entender los desafíos para superar la
crisis climática nos esperamos en otro
episodio de en 5 minutos en francés 24